all right magic
hello magic where are you from where'd
you grow up
i grew up in california moreno valley
riverside
area okay
you came to l.a what age i came to oh
i came to la around probably
17 but i never stayed out here i just
came visiting and [__] i mean stuff
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents when you were a
kid
yeah i had two parents when i was a kid
um but i was adopted so
oh you're right yeah so at what age
like a baby baby baby from birth or stay
out
yeah i understood um yeah but they were
amazing they were amazing so good
childhood
great great childhood yeah
and do you know anything about your
birth parents no nothing
nothing i just know they're like good
people i mean at least they didn't you
know
i'm talking about your birth parents
yeah they had to be in good people to
give me away instead of killing me
oh i see there's abortion and then
there's adoption
they're smart that's an interesting way
of looking at it
and uh you went to how was school you
what kind of kid were you in high school
i was smart very smart it's just
i was i just didn't want to do school no
more so
i had to dropped out i did
10th and 11th but i only got my 10th
grade credits
so but i dropped out because i fought
this girl
and they expelled me because put her in
the hospital so
you're a fighter yeah no i'm not no
fighter it's just
when i get angry i see red so
it was just red i think that makes you a
fighter
so you started working as a prostitute
at what age
18 the um a week after
my birthday i lost my virginity when i
was 18 years old
and that's how i got introduced to the
game
and it was just i seen
something different in a different type
of way to get
money like not no job or working a nine
to five i mean some work nine of fives
like
still with this prostituting or whatever
you want to call it
but that's not how i seen it i just seen
it in a better way of
getting bred and less how do you say
less tiresome like you don't have to
work too hard to get
some money like your rent i don't have
to work too hard to pay
rent like but uh just because you lost
your virginity at 18 doesn't
introduce you to prostitution
necessarily um
i lost my virginity to a pound
yes there you go that's that that was
the missing link
there you go and i didn't know until
after
and then i was like oh
so i just he showed me how to do the
game and then
i took it and i ran with it
i took it and i ran with it so
just me and
do you recall your first time doing it
for money no
i lost my oh oh yeah
heck yeah it was amazing he was like
can i have um can i have your anal i was
like hey no
i was like yeah you got 500 he said yeah
baby yeah and then he just handed me the
money
the [__] put it in my [__] and i was i
was literally just lost my virginity so
he was like it's so tight and i'm like
yeah
[__] so he didn't know he didn't know
he didn't know he put it in
he didn't know and i really didn't care
i got my money i really didn't care it
was just
and then after that he was like can we
do it again and i was like
give me some more money we could do it
as long as you want you know
just cool like that that was the it was
amazing
it wasn't even hurtful or nothing
because he was like
tiny so it was cool and
your experience so how old are you i am
20. you're 20. so this is
this is still a fairly new thing for you
a couple years oh i
i i did it for a couple months and then
like i stopped i did it for like about
nine ten months and then i stopped for
the rest
for like a year and a half and now
you're back at it yeah
yeah because i'm like in my head i don't
know i just had an urge
to that's what i wanted to do so that
was my urge to do it
so you you actually enjoy it yes i do
i i take pride in my game too so
i mean the kind of guys who pick you up
you
what's what's your opinion of them you
respect them you enjoy them
yeah as long as you respect me i will
respect you
i give you what you give me you give me
a good time i give you a great time
it's like you're spending all night with
them no i'm just giving you what you
want from me
and then get about your day just like me
i'm gonna
go get more of what i want and give
people what they want
like what they pick me up for assuming
you have a lot of repeat customers
yeah yeah well um because i stopped
if i like showed my face like i haven't
you know so if i showed my face yeah
they would
come running but i haven't showed my
face yet it's just i went on this street
yeah big so yeah it's kind of new there
and what was your experience working
figure out
i had bad addicts
i had the worst experience what happened
i
i didn't know i couldn't do it and
i was in these hills and all of a sudden
a whole bunch of
pimps get out their cars and they
surround me but
you know i don't know the game too well
but i kind of know the game you see
you're in the hills there's no hills on
figaro street
i think there's hills all the [__]
wear hills oh heels
yeah these are the hills oh there are
heels on the sides
but figure out it's flat from downtown
to the to the south bay
on the sidewalks the sidewalks are
broken
that's for sure yeah okay so so so the
pimps
the pimps approach you oh yeah
the pimp broke my nail he pushed me on
the floor and then another pimp
picked me up and i i was just
so in shock i'm like what the [__]
after the pimp picked me up he just
walked away and the other
guy he i guess he spent his game and it
was
that was that and he walked away and i
was like my nail
you know i gotta walk with these like so
you're currently working with the pam
no you're on your own yeah of course
just asking um and what kind of things
have happened to you
have you had customers who've given you
a hard time or been rude or anything
like that
yeah i had i had them very
it's rare though because i'm i'm a
i look so sweet and so nice
yeah my personality i give out for good
vibes so the people who i attract
are good people you know i try not to
i try not to sing how do you say ghetto
to attract
bad people you know like and i try not
to seem like
i'm the [__] the energy you put out kind
of is what you'll attract too
what now the energy you put out is kind
of what you'll attract
yeah so i try to put out great energy
like
good advice good morning you know like
um but have you been in love before in
love
yeah with a girl i've i've never been
with a
guy before that's why this game is so
amazing i've
never been with a guy before i was 18.
i've only been with females so
it's i it was just different
and something i was i was never used to
the first time i gave like a man a hug
like a real man a hug
i threw up like i couldn't stand the
smell of him
like not even just him it was just men
period i couldn't stand the smell of it
like i don't know it just wasn't me
and then i was introduced to some money
with the game so i was like oh i could
take the smell of you men
like as long as you paint me so your
preference is females
yes and how much money do you think
you're making tonight
it depends it depends if it's a good
night or a bad night yeah of course
yeah but it's it beats the money you
might make
getting a job a straight job heck yeah
what's your job paycheck i could make
that
quicker than that two weeks they're
gonna hold your money
yeah i could make it quicker than that i
can't give you a time
limit because every day is different but
and are drugs a part of your life
weed yep this week i smoke weed every
day
all day dream about it
you know i tried i've tried drugs
but they don't stick i don't like them i
don't like nothing going in my nose or
i don't like taking pills i don't like
putting nothing in my
body that you know dr savvy he smoked
weed so i'ma smoke weed too
so i know it's good for you what
emotions do you
experience doing this does it bring up
any
um anger anxiety depression anything
like that um no
or it's just it's just money for you no
i i enjoy it it's
how do you say it brings me a calmness
it brings me calm to know that
i could bring satisfied satisfaction
satisfaction to my pockets
and into somebody else yeah like you
know
there's nothing wrong about it it's
interesting you might be you might be uh
perfectly suited to this this kind of
work
i don't know it's your option to do what
you want to do
so does it make you feel does it boost
your self-esteem doing this
not to say it boosts my self-esteem but
yeah i mean
getting called beautiful every single
day you know by
random people just looking at you and
saying damn you're
drop dead gorgeous like that really does
like you can you can't get that no
better than that like
unless by your loved one you know
hearing that
you get used to it though you know you
already know that's how they feel you
know so
but hearing it from someone else it just
feels good it feels amazing
do you have a girlfriend currently no i
wish you wish
and if you did would you stop doing
those or you'd continue no
i would not stop for her
[__] she could get on my bandwagon if
she wants
but but no i prefer to
i feel i'm happy doing what i do so i'm
not going to
do do you do you see yourself changing
after doing this i mean do you see
people differently
i see myself elevating yes so in a
different type of level i will still be
doing this
but it will be on a higher platform the
casinos or whatever
yeah something like that yeah a little
making even more money yeah but it's a
crazy way to make money
yeah it's crazy it's it's not
just crazy though because i mean there's
a whole lot of crazy i've been
stabbed before i've been
dragged out the core i've been like my
body
i've been shot at like i have
scars from this that's what i'm saying
but i love it because like
it just makes me happy not just not not
the bad experiences make me happy
it's just to know that you're gonna get
through it but it's
it's still like every day you go out or
get into a
a trick car you could die like
that's all that's in my head but i never
think about nothing bad because
positivity is all i want in my life
but what kind of things does a girl need
to know when she's doing this kind of
work like
making sure the car door opens from the
inside yeah okay
let him you have to have him i don't
understand why y'all go to the side
where
he he he's at to yeah no
make him show you his dick okay period
no cop will show you his dream to make
sure he's out of
go to the passenger side door make sure
that [__] rode all the way down
if he black don't get in the car if he
mixed with black don't get in the court
if he sound black don't get in the court
like black don't give them the court
okay pimp don't get in the court if he
if he came
at you like a pimp but then he was like
oh i want to spend some money
don't get in the court like you know why
why are black guys trouble
pimps they just want your money they
just
they either want your money yeah there
you go i want your time or something
like
nah sorry you where where is the
the asians the hispanics the white guys
are just looking to have some fun
yeah they just want to they just want
your time they want to pay you
and get on they want to go home to their
wife and kids okay
they want to go to work in the morning
with satisfaction satisfaction yeah
how many how many of your customers you
think are married
most of them i had about i could say
70 70 of them
like 70 men i know like regularly
only have girlfriends and single
but married i dated about a thousand
two thousand men who was married how
many men you think you've been with
married men no just men period
about three thousand i really cannot
tell you i i
i'll just be getting in the courts
getting my money yeah and you're
spending money
yeah yeah you put in the bank no bank
you put in a shoe box under the bed i'm
not going to tell you where i put my
money
but i put it in a pocket right
you know you put it somewhere but yeah
not a bank that's interesting
yeah what they gonna ask me where am i
getting right so you have a very
interesting perspective on this
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking about doing this um
because some girl is gonna see this and
be like this that's for me she looks
happy
yeah i'm happy you just follow your
heart
your gut is the only thing you need to
trust in this game
your gut is literally going to save your
life
if your gut rumble if you have a second
thought on something go with go with it
like don't if you
like oh i want to get in oh maybe i
shouldn't intuition [__] maybe you
shouldn't you know like
intuition's the key yeah that's you got
to keep it
keep in mind that that's one thing you
have to
stay true to yourself and your mind and
your gut
like girl because or
however you girl gay trans i don't know
and would you get asked to do risky
things like without a condom
oh yeah i'm not doing that don't do no
bareback don't do that don't do that
don't do that don't lower yourself
don't do that like he will he will give
you
as much as you want
and you still can use a condom
okay condom like there's girl condoms
like if he doesn't want to put a condom
on [__] you put a condom on and then
like make him put a condom on like [__]
you talking about
there's girl condoms for this [__] so
even if
he tries to pop it still you just make
sure you're protected
okay make sure your safety and your
health
is a1 okay that's it because you can't
you you can't be out here doing this
and you got some like [__] if you got
something around your lip
you've been doing very back like we all
know we see it
and we don't want to hang out with you
but we ain't going to judge you
we ain't going to judge you what's the
most important thing you've learned
in your in your 20 years and what 20
years um
love your mama love your mama
your mama and your daddy what do your
parents think of your lifestyle what do
they know
she knows that i am
doing what i want to do she knows that i
am doing what i want to do
she does not think it's the best for me
but i am happy doing what i want to do
and
i cannot put myself in a place where i'm
not happy
like you taught me to be happy like i'm
happy girl
you understand that a lot of girls i've
interviewed have had stories of guys
that you know
tie them up and put them in oh trunks
i've been tied up i've i've been through
the works with this
game told you i've been dragged wrong
like i guess you've had your share
i got a whole lot to show i have my
proofs on my body like you're a survivor
yeah
and i'm enjoying what i do but i just
i just stay mindful like i will never
retrace the step that put me in the
situation like
i know what i did wrong and i will try
to go around it
you know just instincts
trust him i didn't trust my i didn't
trust my gut i didn't go through the
only reason i
this happened is because i didn't trust
my gut that's why i went through what i
went through
[Music]
all right magic thank you so much for
sharing your story
no problem and i'm glad you're having a
good time you too
be careful out there me too thanks
oh my god you're so fun
you